[Music]
was made of protons neutrons and
electrons the first two in the nucleus
the third around it is mostly empty
space but it feels solid in any case the
elements are all the different types of
atoms but differ by the number of
protons in the middle hydrogen is only
one but uranium has time oh it's just
camp uh uh street that you and me are
[Music]
atoms bond together to form molecules
most of one surrounded me and you water
sugar thing said I'm dreamed up ah look
around you see the combinations in a
eucalypt rate Mandalay it was
periodicity gives us sand water and the
every Bob oh it's just can a stream that
you and me are made of these atoms
hydrogen oxy
Jim car ball night drogyn make up the
world life bones
to do to do to do to do to do you wonder
how mad upon something strange when
there's a chemical change
[Music]
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba wit did these
atoms come from they were fused in stars
by elements combine releasing life from
afar of fusion in the Sun creates Healy
YUM
I guess what I'd be saying is you gotta
use your reason to open up your mind and
see the cause of the seasons how do we
know what's true a scientific method
shows you and it's just camp a street
that you and me are made of these times
I was born together to form molecules
most of what surrounded me and you water
sugar sand and you'll find things I
dreamed of so our company on Zenon
there's no need to overstate cuz we are
a course this abyss of this world I